[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who is something of a society
himself and we have a whole host of new
justice league schneiderkr updates that
we need to talk about
zach has just dropped a big interview
with vanity fair discussing the true
story behind this cut of justice league
and the issues that we never knew about
until now in this video we're going to
be going over
all as well as some of the new images of
the film including a jesus christ joker
that some are saying is god awful i have
a different opinion though but we'll get
into it later on
and if you enjoy the video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so the article goes into a lot of
information on both the production of
justice league
the death of zack's daughter and the
general feeling towards this release
justice league is a strange story that's
difficult to really fully comprehend in
its entirety
due to the sheer amount of back and
forth that there was behind the scenes
there were constant production changes
that ultimately led to the mess that we
got
and the potential vindication that is
coming around the corner now though
snyder's name
is in the credits of the theatrical
release it has been widely said that
snyder himself has never actually
watched it
and the vanity fair article starts off
by saying that it was his wife deborah
who advised him not to
deborah is a high-ranking producer and
warner brothers and even though she has
a lot of power within the company
the article states that it didn't really
allow for her to intervene
in what was clearly a mess it turns out
that the film was actually shown to
deborah and a number of high-ranking
warner brothers associates
including christopher nolan deborah
stated it was just weird
it's a weird experience i don't know how
many people have that experience
you've worked on something for a long
time and then you leave and then you see
what happened to it
together she and nolan made a pact that
they would make sure
zach never saw it and to this day he
still hasn't
now we of course know what the result of
the film was and it becomes clear when
reading the work that warner brothers
were a team of executives who were very
much like the league themselves
constantly in doubt over their actions
batman v superman had underperformed
both critically and commercially
and dc believed that the reason marvel
outperformed them was because of the
studio's vibrant and colorful characters
it then came a big turning point when
autumn snyder sadly took her own life
after battling with depression this was
a massively tragic moment for the
snyders
and exhausted from battling with the
studio they decided to put the focus of
their fighting spirit
back onto their family the snyder cut
will be dedicated to zack's daughter
and the director confirmed that the
movie will end with the words for autumn
appearing in the credits the article is
very heartbreaking
as it does go into his daughter's death
and their life together
throughout it snyder refers to her as
the only dawker of his children
and still talks about autumn in the
present tense showing how much he still
loves her
it turns out that hallelujah was
actually her favorite song
and this also explains why it's so
layered throughout snyder's work
at the end of the scenario cut the song
will be performed by alison crowe
who also sang it at autumn's funeral it
is of course totally understandable why
he wanted to step back
but he and deborah did soldier on for
two months trying to get the film
finished
however the constant battles and anguish
that they must have faced
would have torn most people apart i
don't think that anyone could blame them
in the slightest for stepping back
however their departure left a huge
vacuum that needed to be filled
though it was always publicized that
snyder hand picked his replacement
this was far from the truth and thus
warner bros turned to someone who had
already pulled off the superhero team
formula
that was joe sweden the director of
avengers
who had clearly caught lightning in a
bottle whilst working for marvel
and whatever you think of the director
as a person professionally
it's easy to see why his comic book
movies are held in such high regards
the director was brought on to quote
unquote save the project
but as the saying goes you either die
the hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain
warner bros didn't like the first cut of
the film and they wanted the reshoots
accomplished quickly
but it's now become clear that whedon
took on a lot more than he was expected
to
and he completely changed the film and
direction of the universe
justice league was hated by critics
mocked because of its lackluster cgi
and it turns out that the behavior on
set was worse than henry kevin's
mustache
vanity fair states that in public
everyone involved with the movie smiled
but it was a big financial loss for the
studio and it was dwarfed less than a
year later by infinity war which
completely dusted the film at the box
office
it's a shame because this movie had so
much potential
the article discusses when snyder first
cast gal gadot in batman v superman
and how this pretty much changed her
life forever gadot was on the brink of
quitting the business and being done
with hollywood
but this was her last audition so she
thought she'd go along
snyder instantly fell in love with her
take and the rest is of course history
snyder really wanted to reinvent these
characters and offer new interpretations
that hadn't been seen before
this was of course present in his man of
steel take but it was also brought
across to his version of aquaman
a character who up until this point had
been seen as a joke
snyder said that the studio gave him the
power to do whatever he wanted
but this always meant that he went
somewhere other than they wanted
the interview mentions that originally
snyder wanted to have bruce wayne fall
in love with lois lane
and though their names rhymed i did
kinda roll my eyes at this bit when
reading it
and it seems like warner brothers did
too as they stepped in and put a stop to
it
snyder stated the intention was that
bruce fell in love with lois
and then realized that the only way to
save the world was to bring superman
back to life
so he had this conflict because lois of
course was still in love with superman
snyder said we had this beautiful speech
where bruce said to alfred
i never had a life outside of the cave i
never imagined a world for me beyond
this but this woman makes me think that
if i can get this group of gods together
then my job is done i can quit i can
stop
and that of course doesn't work out for
him now personally i can see why warner
brothers were hesitant over this
direction too
and it's probably because of ideas like
this that they started to try and reign
in the director
we now know that though snyder wasn't
fired because of his choices
he was still heavily watched warner
brothers appointed people to look over
him
in the form of jeff jones and john berg
who had their own ideas for the
production
no matter what at least one of them had
to be on set every day
and the control snyder had slowly
started to be reined in
and turned to the dark side warner bros
wanted
a big billion dollar blockbuster that
broke the bank at the box office
and they put the two watch dogs on him
to make sure that the movie performed to
their high expectations
however their choices probably did more
harm than help
snyder said that he felt they were there
to pretty much babysit him
and the pair attempted to inject humor
into the piece even though it wasn't
really the tone
that zach was going for the ceo at
warner brothers
also saw a curve the film and he wanted
to make several changes to the movie
including its length warner brothers
wanted to be able to show the movie as
many times as possible as they could
throughout the day in cinemas
and thus a two-hour length was mandated
and forced upon zack
this of course caused issues as senator
had already built certain parts of the
film
to rely on well other parts of the film
if you've seen the ultimate edition of
batman v superman then you'll know that
the entire movie feels like a house of
cards
and when you remove one the entire thing
falls down and you pretty much get the
theatrical cut
this was very much the same with justice
league and snyder struggled with
introducing six characters
and an alien in two hours i think the
biggest criticism that everyone lobbies
at dc when discussing why they fell
short of marvel is because the latter
had several movies setting up all of the
characters in the avengers
so that by the time they met the studio
could just hit the ground running
they also had a bigger run time too but
warner bros were clearly trying to
force the film to be as profitable as
possible at the expense of the film
itself
thus they ended up butting heads with
each other at several points
and when snyder stepped away he took his
unfinished cut of justice league on a
laptop
as a memento to show his friends as
mentioned earlier reports about snyder
asking for whedon
were completely false and the work
reveals that jos and jones were planning
a batgirl movie
which we now know won't be happening
during this period he had been recruited
to do some minor rewrites for justice
league
and snyder had been hopeful that he
could add some cool scenes to it
however warner bros slowly gave whedon
more and more power
and he started even directing some
scenes during the reshoots
reeling from their daughter's death and
being disappointed with the work that
they were producing
both the sniders quit and called the
cast and crew one by one
ray fisher devastated by this moment
discussed it in the article and he said
the following
i remember i was in a movie theater
coincidentally enough
i was walking into the amc right in
times square
and i got the call from zach and he was
saying that he had to deal with stuff
with the fam
and he was having to step away i had a
trillion questions
my heart sank from this point onwards
whedon took the reins
and rerolled and re-shot 75 percent of
the movie
this was now clearly his film and the
studio
weren't too happy with it either this
was actually touched upon in the
interview itself
as an anonymous studio exec revealed the
vanity fair the following
when we got to see what joss actually
did it was stupefying
the robber on the rooftop so goofy and
awful
the russian family so useless and
pointless
everyone knew it it was so awkward
because nobody wanted to admit
what a piece of [ __ ] it was this dismay
over the project of course carried
across to the screen
and since then it's become clear that on
set it wasn't all sunshine and snack
holes
ray fisher has publicly come out and
said numerous times that whedon was
abusive
and that warner brothers also enabled
this gal gadot too came forward and said
that she had a negative experience with
the director which was reported to
higher ups
we now know that warner brothers have
taken action though they are
tight-lipped over what this entails
however whedon has stepped down from his
sci-fi show than eva's and it doesn't
seem like
jeff jones will be working with the
company again after fans were
disappointed across the board by
whedon's take
many wanted to see the original version
of the film and thus a movement on
social media started
namely the hashtag release the snyder
cut now snyder does admit that he
encouraged this over time but that it
seemed like a pipe dream that wasn't
really where his focus was at
after all it did take 20 years for us to
get the richard danika of superman 2
and it just feels like snyder wasn't too
invested in the movement when it first
began
when discussing the heir after his
departure the director said the
following
from the time we left it was not a great
year but we did a lot of stuff with
family
it was really important and important
yeah
zach decided to take a long time away
from hollywood so that he and his family
could heal
but it's clear that his hunger didn't
die down he began working on army of the
dead
which is due to release later in the air
scott stuber head of films at netflix
discussed why the studio decided to work
with the director
and they said zach went through
something very difficult
and i think he probably realized like we
all do it's okay to be vulnerable
for those of us lucky enough to know him
and deborah he's a very soulful
kind thoughtful human being he's got
this facade of big action movies and all
these bravado things
there's a sweet kindness to him this of
course juxtaposes
several creators who are now being
exposed as being abusive in hollywood
and even the execs who've often been on
opposite ends of the spectrum to snyder
have said that he's a genuinely nice
person that crafts a gentle work
environment that values the cast and
crew
now as for the laptop with the original
cut on this was devoid of special
effects
and didn't have a full score it was also
in black and white
and to snyder it was more just something
to show his friends and family
but momentum for the movement continued
to grow and it wasn't too long before
everything warner brothers put
out was hounded by the hashtag fans
bought planes to fly banners above the
studio
and they pulled together money to rent a
times square billboard advertising the
campaign
gal gadot and affleck also called for it
to be released
and it wasn't too long before warner
brothers began to pay attention
during this time the fanbase also
managed to do a lot of positive things
and so far they've raised over half a
million dollars in charity money for the
american foundation for suicide
prevention
that wasn't too long before the hashtag
got seen by toby emerick
who met with snyder after it trended due
to the efforts of the fans and cast
emrick said a lot of people at the
company myself included
always felt badly that zack didn't get
to finish his vision of the film
because of the circumstances so if there
was a way to make it logistically
and financially possible which hbo max
did
and zack had a willingness to do it it
seemed like a win for everybody
snyder did state in the article that the
studio just wanted to release the black
and white footage with no additional
effects
but he turned this down they were a bit
put back by this
and didn't understand why he wouldn't
want it out to which he replied
here's why three reasons one you get the
internet off your back
which is probably your main reason for
wanting to do this
two you get to feel vindicated for
making things right i guess
on some level and three you get a shitty
version of the movie
that you can point out and go see it's
not that good anyway
so maybe i was right i was like no
chance
i would rather just have the snyder cut
be a mythical unicorn for all time
now we know this hardball worked and at
the moment it's estimated that the
snyder cut is up
in the region of 70 million dollars in
budget snyder did clarify that he's not
getting a paycheck this time
but for waving his fee he wants full
creative control
it's a pretty smart move too as if he's
not charging anything
then the studio can't threaten to take
away the money as an incentive
the other cast members were eager to
return to including ray fisher
who said that he's thought about this
movie every day for the last three years
cyborg had a much more substantial arc
in the original story
the fans are delighted we will now get
to see snyder also isn't beholden to
dc's current canon
and can take the story wherever he
pleases and this includes a jesus joker
which has just been shown in the
marketing for the movie alongside this
article
although they send some people off into
hysterics i actually think that snyder
is showing he's got the last laugh
often criticized for using over jesus
imagery in his movies
he's rolled with it and done the most on
the nose thing possible to poke fun at
his critics
having a gyroletto joker dressed up as
jesus while saying we live in a society
is such a meme that it's almost
impossible to not gawk at how hilarious
the idea really is
snyder has really stopped caring about
what his critics think of him
and he's willing to fight back by
embracing everything they label him as
which is such a smart move when you ask
his fans now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on this story and if
there's anything we missed then comment
below and let me know
i've left the article linked in the
description as well if you want to go
and read it as it goes into much more
detail and it's a very good read
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase three 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the story
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the commercials for one division which
will be linked on screen right now
we went through them all and pointed out
all the hidden meanings and messages
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace